قبل سنوات كان العالم على موعد مع فضيحه
شهيره ادت الى دمار الكره الايطاليه
لسنوات واليوم في اسبانيا يبدو الامر ربما
سيتكرر مساله تعلق هذه المره بازمه فزاد
او فساد تلاحق احد النوادي المفضله
للجمهور العربي نادي الكتالوني برشلونه
النادي الكتالوني يوجه عاصفه من التهم فكل
انديه دوري الاسباني تشكو من شبهه رشوه
الحكام التي يتم بها عده اشخاص داخل وخارج
النادي هذه هي الاتهامات الزم وضع برشلونه
الذي يعاني من مشكله اقتصاديه كبيره خصوصا
بحال ثبتت هذه الاتهامات على ناجي المساله
ليست بسيطه ابدا بالنسبه لبرشلونه فالنادي
مهدد بالافلاس وربما الانهيار تفاصيل
القضيه الماليه مع زميلنا على سرحان
في تفاصيل قضيه الفساد في النادي الكتلوني
اتهم القضاء الاسباني نادي برشلونه
ورئيسيه السابقين ساند وجوسيد بارتوميو
والمسؤول التحكيم السابق حسين جريره
بالفساد واساءه الامانه وتزوير سجلات
تجاريه القضاء الاسباني وجه الاتهامات
ايضا الى اوسكار جراو والبرت سولار اللذين
كان يعملان في اداره بارتوميو حيث تتمحور
التهم حول دفع اكثر من سبعه ملايين دولار
لنيجريره بين عامي
1994 و 2018 اداره برشلونه الحاليه بقياده
جوان لابورتا اكدت قبل ايام ان النادي
الكتلوني لم يشتري حكاما يوما ولم يكن له
نيه في فعل مثل هذه الاشياء محملا رئيس
رابطه الدوري الاسباني مساله الحمله
المزعومه ضد برشلونه انديه الدوري
الاسباني وصفت القضيه بالخطيره جدا مؤكده
ضروره كشف ما شابه من مخالفات فيما اعدى
ريال مدريد نفسه ناد متضرر من قضيه نادي
برشلونه ونائب رئيس الحكام السابق خوسيه
[موسيقى]
ينضم لنا في الاستديو عبد الجواد الرشد
المراسل الصباح العربيه عبد الجواد اهلا
بك معانا منورنا في الاستوديو اليوم صباح
الخير
الله يسلمكم منورين نادي برشلونه يعاني
اليوم من ازمه قد تدمر النادي الكتالوني
ما سبب هذه الازمه ما الذي حصل تحديدا ومن
المتهمه يعني اعتقد ان هذه الفقاعه الان
التي تدور حول نادي برشلونه هيا لمرحله
جزئيه يعني هذا الشيء يعود لعده اسباب
طبعا لم يرق هذا الشيء لنادي ريال مدريد
او انديه اخرى باعتبار انا برشلونه
في الدوري الاسباني وقد يظهر في هذا اللقب
لكن طبعا اذا ما تم الاخذ بعين الاعتبار
قضيه كره القدم والدوري الاسباني الذي
يعني يحظى بشعبيه كبيره في العالم وخاصه
في الشرق الاوسط والعالم العربي نلاحظ بان
برشلونه يعني خلال
العقدين الاخيرين يعني لا يحتاج
للعب بنتائج المباريات
[موسيقى]
يتوقع ولا حتى اكثر المتفائلين بعوده
برشلونه بهذه القوه ومنافسه ريال مدريد
منافسه انديه اخرى على هذا اللقب لذلك
لابد من لفت الانتباه الى موضوع معدل ان
برشلونه في 2014 كان بحاجه الفوز على
اتلتيكو مدريد في المباراه الاخيره للفوز
باللقب لانه سقط في فقط تعادل لذلك طبعا
توجيه اصابع الاتهام نحو برشلونه بشراء
المباريات
بالرغم من ان الفساد موجود في كره القدم
والجميع يعرف يعني قضيه دفع الرشا شراء
الحكام ان كان هذا الشيء في اكبر في اكبر
البطولات ببطوله كاس العالم لا احد ينسى
التامر الكبير بين المانيا والنمسا على
منتخب الجزائر
يعني هو تامر كبير طبعا اخرج الجزائر
من كاس العالم بينما الجزائر الحقت
الهزيمه بالمانيا اثنين واحد في ذلك الوقت
لذلك طبعا هي فقاعه
رشوه رئيس نادي الكتالوني الحالي يقول انه
لم يرش الحكام وانه اشار او لما الى ازمه
مع رئيس رابطه
يعني لابد له من الخروج والحديث للصحافه
حول براءه هذا الموضوع الفساد موجود يعني
لا يمكن الوصول له هناك بعض الشخصيات
المقربه من امور كره القدم يعرفون جيدا ان
امور الفساد هي امر واقعي لكن الشخصيات
الكبيره في عالم كره القدم الانديه
الكبيره لا يمكن ان تقوم بالتصرف بامور
صبيانيه خاصه ان المدرب حينها كان
جوارديولا وجوارديولا طبعا اليوم يهدد
نادي مانشستر سيتي بالخروج في حال كان
الكبير مانشستر سيتي يلعب على قضيه اللعب
غير نظيف المالي طيب في هذه الحاله الى
اين يمكن ان تصل العقوبات ضد برشلونه في
حال مثلا الموجهه للنادي طبعا هي ستكون
ازمه كبيره باعتبار ان برشلونه هو احد
اقطاب ليست دوري الاسباني فقط هو احد
اقطاب انديه كره القدم الاوروبيه اتوقع ان
الامور ستجري على ما يرام بكل بساطه يعني
شاهدنا الضربات في الدوري طبعا يعني هو
تفاؤل ليس من واقع محبته لبرشلونه او ريال
مدريد او شيء اخر يعني عندما تتحدثين عن
فريق يضم ضم هذه يعني اي كوكبه من النجوم
هو يعني تنافس معه من كريستيانو رونالدو
الى رونالدينيو الى يعني اكبر النجوم في
العالم هي اهانه لكره القدم عندما نعرف ان
من يعشقه في العالم لعب في ملف الفساد
هناك اسماء لان ننكرها نزمه احد اقطاب
الكره الاسبانيه نادي الكتالوني كيف ستؤثر
على الكره الاسبانيه طبعا ستؤثر بشكل كبير
وبالذات في حال ثبوت امور بهذا الموضوع قد
يتعرض الفريق لمخالفات ماليه قد يتعلق
يتعرض لعقوبات قد يتعرق يتعرض للدخول
ونزول يعني يهبط الى الدرجه الثانيه لذلك
طبعا هي قضيه يعني متاحه كل الخيارات فيها
لكن حسب الخبراء من العيار الثقيل في عالم
كره القدم هذه الازمه ستمر اتمنى يعني هي
ضربه قاسيه لعشره صحيح شكرا يا عبد الجواد
رشد
الملم بكل الشؤون ليس فقط الروسيه
كمراسلنا في موسكو وايضا في الرياضيات
منها كل التحيه كل التحيه منورين على طول
وراء الكواليس يعني انا حدا بيعشق لبنان
كتير وبيعشق فيروز كتير مع انه انا سوري
يعني كل يوم الصبح في عندي بحبك يا لبنان
يا وطني بس كنت بالسياره ولا بالبيت لكن
صار لي اكثر من سنه بقوم الصباح بشغل صباح
العربيه
وبيروق نهاري بطريقه كتير حلوه لذلك
منورين على طول يا سهام ونادين تحيه لكل
فريق العمل وكل عام وانتم بالف خير يعني
هاي فعلا مفاجاه كانت حلوه منك تسلم شكرا
شكرا